[Musique]
et on commence avec le sénateur du jour
Bernard delcro bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur centriste du Cantal
vice-président de la commission des
finances on va commencer d'abord par une
réaction au décès de Gérard colon
l'ancien maire de Lyon ex-ministre de
l'Intérieur marcheur soutien d'Emmanuel
Macron de la première heure vous
qu'est-ce que vous retenez de ce
personnage politique le le parcours de
de Gérard colon est marqué à la fois par
ces Mandal locau c'est un homme de
terrain attaché chacun le sait à sa
ville de Lyon qui l'a transformé c'est
lui qui a été à l'origine de la création
de la métropole de Lyon donc à la fois
un homme de terrain attaché à Lyon et
puis aussi ses mandats nationaux et
notamment au ministère de de l'intérieur
et je crois que Gérard colon était un
homme lucide il connaissait les réalités
du du pays et il a voulu à un moment
alerter en quelque sorte sur les
fractures qui traversent le pays qui ont
été d'ailleurs révélées avec les
violences qui se sont développées mais
des fractures qui concern pas seulement
les questions urbaines je pense il y a
aussi des fractures et je pense que
c'était aussi dans sa euh dans dans dans
sa ligne lorsqu'il a prononcé cette
phrase des fractures entre les
métropoles et le secteur rural et je
pense que la priorité aujourd'hui l'une
des priorités de notre pays c'est
d'apaiser c'est d'apaiser c'est de
réparer essayer essayer de rassembler
les Français autour autour d'un ob d'un
objectif commun pour le pays donc pour
vous Gérard colon a raison aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui en France nous vivons face à
face par par exemple quand on voit ce
qui s'est passé ce weekend à roman sur
RER alors je veux pas dire face à face
mais en tous les cas on voit bien qu'il
y a des fractures qui depuis sa date pas
d'hier qui depuis des années et des
années au fil du temps se sont creusé
dans le pays d'où les violences urbaines
d'où les incompréhensions du monde rural
par rapport à un certain nombre de
choses et donc oui je pense que les
fractures se sont accentuées depuis
plusieurs décennies et qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une priorité de er ces ces
fractures d'apaiser le pays si on veut
pas justement avoir de France l'une face
à l'autre alors Bernard delcron on va
parler du budget 2024 qui est examiné en
ce moment au Sénat d'ailleurs vous avez
fini la nuit dernière à 2h du matin je
crois on va dans quelques instants
évoquer les amendements centristes qui
ont été débattus que vous avez proposé
mais d'abord d'une manière générale à
quoi ça sert pour le Sénat d'examiner ce
budget 2024 alors qu'on sait forcément
qu'il sera passé en force à l'Assemblée
au 493 avec le voilà avec cet outil cons
et que le gouvernement et bien retiendra
ce qu'il souhaite dans ce texte alors je
je je ne je ne le pense pas pour vous
c'est un intérêt je pense que au
contraire la situation politique et
notamment la situation à l'Assemblée
nationale où il y a pas de majorité si
ce n'est relative pour l'exécutif je
pense que le rôle du Sénat est devenu
tout à fait essentiel central et je
pense que le travail qui est fait au
Sénat alors évidemment tout ne sera pas
retenu je l'imagine bien mais je pense
qu'il y a un certain nombre de prop
opposition d'avancer voter au Sénat j'en
suis absolument convaincu qui seront
retenus au final dans ce qu'on a
l'habitude d'appeler le le 493 donc le
rôle du Sénat est important parce que
précisément le défaut de majorité à
l'Assemblée lui permett de de de de
voter des des des décisions qui seront
retenues dans le dans 493 et sur la
structure de ce budget 2024 de manière
générale vos collègues de la droite
sénatoriale estiment que le gouvernement
gère mal les finances publiques ne
propose pas assez d' vous êtes d'accord
alors il y a une différence entre entre
nous c'est que nous nous pensons
évidemment qu'il faut faire des
économies et nous avons des propositions
pour faire des économies mais le le pays
a aussi besoin de moyens supplémentaires
dans des domaines qui sont cruciaux la
santé l'éducation la justice la
transition écologique la sécurité la
défense personne ne le conteste donc
pour arriver à tenir cette ligne de
crête en quelque sorte redresser les
finances publiques réduire les
déficits mieux contenir l'endettement et
en même temps répondre aux besoins du
pays nous nous pensons qu'il faut aussi
agir sur les recettes et que nous devons
avoir aussi une ligne de justice fiscale
parce qu'au moment où on demande
beaucoup d'efforts au français au moment
où on demande beaucoup d'efforts au
français je pense que il faut aussi que
la justice fiscale marque ce budget et
que les plus fortunés je parle des des
grandes fortunes ceux qui perçoivent des
des dividendes extraordinaires puissent
participer davantage à la solidarité
pour redresser les finances publiques
bien justement on va en parler de cette
justice fiscale qui est prenée par les
sénateurs centristes on accueille notre
journaliste parlementaire Mathias
[Musique]
SZ bonjour Mathias bonjour Alexandre
bonjour monsieur le sén bonjour Alors
Mathias on peut dire que ce weekend au
Sénat dans l'examen du budget bien ce
sont les sénateurs centristes qui ont
joué les premiers rôles absolument on
connaît le rôle de faiseur de roi du
groupe centriste ici au Sénat Alexandre
et bien ce weekend encore pendant
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
cela c'est à nouveau confirmé première
mesure notable la Haute Assemblée a
adopté le remplacement de l'IFI en nifi
soit la transformation de l'impôt sur la
fortune immobilière en impôt sur la
fortune improductive alors un changement
substantiel de cet impôt qui était censé
remplacer l'impôt sur la fortune
supprimé par Emmanuel Macron en 2017 on
s'en souvient mais qui selon beaucoup
d'observateurs ne remplissait pas
totalement sa fonction une petite
victoire donc pour les centristes mais
qui reste pour leur incertaine puisqu'un
amendement similaire avait été adopté
l'an dernier avant de faire les frais de
la navette parlementaire alors ce n'est
pas qu'un changement euh sémantique
c'est aussi le changement du champ
d'action de ce nouvel impôt sur la
fortune improductive le champ d'action a
été élargi c'est ça et ça va faire
grincer des dents forcément cette
nouvelle version de l'IFI prévoit
notamment de taxer les yachts les jets
privés les voitures les objets précieux
les bitcoins mais seront aussi inclus
dans le calcul de l'impôt les terrains
constructibl lorsqu'ils ne sont pas
affectés à une activité économique les
liquidités et placements financiers
assimilés entendez compte courant
livrait fonds monétaires ou encore les
droits de la propriété littéraire
artistique et industriel lorsque le
redevable n'est ni l'auteur ni
l'inventeur et ça forcément ben le
gouvernement n'est pas très fan
travaillons à une échelle plus grande
que le seul territoire national sinon
renforcer la fiscalité sur le patrimoine
à l'échelle des particuliers n'aura que
pour effet d'inciter au départ d'une
certaine manière et jouera à la fois
contre cont l'attractivité du pays et
même contre nos propres recettes
fiscales monsieur delcoss cet amendement
avait été adopté l'an dernier au Sénat
avant de faire les frais de la navette
parlementaire est-ce que vous poussez
pour que cette fois il est un autre
destin alors je ne connais pas quel sera
son destin mais nous sommes attachés à
cette mesure qui est
complètement juste en quelque sorte
lorsque l'ISF a été supprimé l'objectif
affiché c'était de taxer la fortune
productive euh et de ne pas taxer la
fortune ou les les opérations
productives on la cible n'est pas
atteinte vous avez cité les exemples
aujourd'hui un avion privé un yacht ne
sont pas taxés mais quelqu'un qui
investit dans un petit immeuble de
centrebourg pour créer du logement
social là on va le faire rentrer ce ce
ce ce patrimoine dans l'impôt sur la
fortune alors que c'est un
investissement productif puisqu'on
resture du patrimoine puisqu'on on
soutient l'activité économique locale et
l'emploi puisqu'on crée du logement qui
permet de loger des familles je pense
qu'on est dans un investissement qui lui
est productif donc nous voulons rétablir
cet équilibre et donc plus de justice
sur cette mesure aussi et qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de l'argument qui a été
avancé par le gouvernement qui était
contre votre proposition car le
gouvernement estime que taxer encore
plus le patrimoine des particuliers ça
va nuire à l' à l'attractivité de notre
pays mais aujourd'hui le le patrimoine
bâti est taxé euh et vous avez du
patrimoine non bâti les capitaux
mobiliers on l'a dit le Yach vous avez
pris l'exemple la avion privé qui ne
sont pas taxés est-ce juste est-ce que
le yacht est-ce que l'avion privé c'est
de l'investissement ou c'est des
capitaux qui sont est-ce que ce sont des
des fortunes qui sont productives non
alors que je reprends mon exemple créer
du logement social dans un immeuble
c'est un investissement qui est
productif aujourd'hui il les taxés nous
voulons le sortir de l'impôt et le
remplacer donc par des impôts sur les
richesses dont j'ai parlé alors dans ce
débat les sénateurs centristes ont un
peu gagné la bataille sur cet amendement
mais comme il ne peut y avoir que des
victoires et bien Mathias les centristes
ont aussi enregistré un revers on le
sait le groupe d'HV Marseille pousse
depuis de longs mois pour une taxe sur
les super profits lors de cet examen du
budget plusieurs amendements proposant
la création d'une taxation
exceptionnelle des super profits des
entreprises ont donc été déposé par la
gauche mais aussi un par le groupe
centriste et cette fois ça s'est joué à
très peu de choses Alexandre on regarde
justement le vote qui est
pour
10 11 12 1 14 15 alors je vais vous
demander de faire un assis debout
veuillez m'excuser mais c'est pas si
clair donc qui que ceux qui sont pour se
lèvent s'il vous plaît très bien qui est
contre merci de vous lever pour ceux qui
sont
contre égalité de voix il n'est donc pas
adopté ça c'est historique com ça s'est
joué à une seule voix donc puis en cas
d'égalité bien c'est ça ne ça ne
remporte pas l'amendement n'est pas
adopté à noter Alexandre que c'est l'une
des séries d'amendements qui a suscité
le plus
d'explication de de vote monsieur delcro
est-ce que vous vous comprenez cette
position du gouvernement qui est
inflexible sur une une taxe sur les
super profit alors nous ne la partageons
pas nous avons fait une série de
propositions qui engendre 10 milliards
d'économie à moment où tout le monde
considère qu'il faut redresser les
comptes publics je pense que cette voie
elle est inévitable euh donc parmi
celle-là il y avait la taxe
exceptionnelle l'impôt la contribution
exceptionnelle sur les super profits qui
effectivement n'a pas été voté mais à
égalité de voix mais nous avons aussi
proposé l'exit taxe qui a été voté
c'est-à-dire les entreprises les
détenteurs d'entreprises qui viennent en
France pour bénéficier des aides des
aides françaises importantes massives
notamment crédit impôt recherche et qui
ensuite au moment de la session se
délocalise à l'étranger ne serait-ce que
2 ans pour échapper à l'impôt français
comment peut-on admettre que des
détenteurs d'entreprise viennent
bénéficier de de d'aide financière
française massive et ensuite échappe à
l'impôt sur les plus-valu elle a été
votée nous avons proposé de taxer les
rachats d'actions c'est-à-dire des des
des grandes entreprises qui rachètent
leurs propres actions pour faire monter
les cours quatre qui ont explosé ces
dernières années près de 90 milliards 87
milliards je crois sur les trois
dernières années elle a été votée nous
avons proposé
d'e une tranche supplémentaire de la
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
hauts revenus dont je rappelle qu'elle a
été mise en place en 20199 donc qu'elle
a été mise en place pardon sous la
présidence de Nicolas Sarkozi et là il
s'agit pas de toucher les classes
moyennes ça concerne ça concerne les les
les personnes les contribuables qui
gagnent 1 million ou plus d'un million
d'euros de revenus par an je pense que
ces fortunesl doivent pouvoir contribuer
encore une fois à la solidarité
nationale pour redresser les finances
publiques par c'est aussi un message
qu'on envoie aux Français c'est un
message qu'on envoie aux Français et je
pense qu'il faut adresser un message de
justice fiscale au français les plus
fortunés doivent contribuer au
redressement des finances publiques en
avec davantage de solidarité pourtant
Thomas casna va répéteré plusieurs fois
tout au long du weekend que le
gouvernement la politique du
gouvernement en matière d'impôt sur les
sociétés était la bonne et que vous vous
porteriez préjudice à leur politique
c'est un autre sujet nous on était
favorable à la diminution d'impô sur les
société qui est passé je le rappelle euh
au cours de ces de ces 5 dernières
années qui est passé de 33,3 % à 25 % en
diminuant l'impôt sur les sociétés on on
on encourage les sociétés à investir
c'est une bonne mesure et d'ailleurs le
produit de l'impôt sur les sociétés en
même temps que la le taux a baissé le
produit a augmenté donc nous on est
favorable à cela c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose que l'exit taxe dont je
viens de parler tout à l'heure ou encore
du rachat d'action dont je viens de
parler c'est deux sujets différents donc
l'impôt sur les sociétés on était
favorable à la baisse bernardcron on va
parler de la ruralité in c'est un sujet
aussi de du débat de ce budget 2024 car
je le précise vous êtes président du
Parlement rural qui regroupe les acteurs
qui œuvre en faveur du monde rural et
dans ce budget et bien le gouvernement
réforme ce qu'on appelle les zones de
revitalisation rural c'està-dire un
dispositif d'ê fiscale pour les communes
rurales pour queelles puissent
redynamiser leur activité économique et
vous vous avez été assez critique sur
cette réforme de la politique d'aide au
milieu rural alors c'est un combat que
j' mène depuis longtemps et peut-être
pour nos téléspectateurs dire un peu de
quoi il s'agit avec les zones de
revittilisation rurale c'est quoi en
fait une commune qui est classée zone de
réalisation rurale il y en a à peu près
17000 ce sont des communes très rurales
en général il y en a à peu près 17000 en
France euh bénéficie de mesures qui
touchent à la fois euh des exonérations
fiscales pour des petites entreprises ou
des professionnels de santé qui
s'installent ou qui reprennent une
activité dans ces communes il y a un
deuxième pilier autour euh du
médico-social avec des exonérations de
charges social c'est très important pour
les associations d'aide à domicile pour
les organismes d'intérêts généraux pour
les les épades c'est un deuxème pilier
qui est très important euh et et et là
on est vraiment sur des sujets où on a
un certain nombre d'associations je
pense aux associations d'aide à domicile
la DMR par exemple c'est pas la seule
qui sont au bord de au bord de la
rupture donc on vient les accompagner et
puis il y a un troisème volet qui est un
volet de soutien aux collectivités dont
on parle peu mais qui existe dans ses
ADR donc c'est très important c'est un
levier important pour soutenir les
territoires ruraux elles ont été menacé
de disparition j'ai fait deux rapports
sur le sujet elles sont sauvées
aujourd'hui et le gouvernement a bien
voulu inscrire leur pérenisation dans le
projet de loi de finance donc elles sont
sauvées et c'est une bonne chose elles
ont été sauvées par le débat au Sénat
alors elles ont été sauvées parce que
elle se termine en fait le le le
dispositif au 31 décembre et donc le
gouvernement en inscrivant leur
pérénisation dans le proet de finances
finalement les pérénisent mais avec une
réforme une première copie de réforme
qui pour nous n'était pas satisfaisante
que nous avons modifié hier mais mais je
dois le dire nous avons trouvé un accord
entre le Sénat et le gouvernement il y a
encore quelques ajustements à faire mais
nous avons trouvé un accord sur la
réforme des adrr qui vont devenir France
ruralité revitalisation donc nous sommes
sur la bonne voie et l'accord a été
trouvé à bien après bien des discussions
et et beaucoup de concertations alors
Bernard delcron on va parler de
l'actualité dans votre région dans le
quantal en auverne grâce à nos
partenaires de la presse quotidienne
régionale on part pour Auriac retrouver
pierre Ren directeur départemental de
l'édition du Cantal à la montagne
bonjour Pierre bonjour à lire dans vos
pages aujourd'hui bien une alerte sur
l'état de la médecine
scolaire tout à fait dans le canta et
vous savez monsieur delcro il est déjà
très compliqué et fastidieux de trouver
un médecin libéral nous avons déjà
multiplié les les sujets dans nos
colonnes sur cette thématique dans notre
édition du jour on s'est intéressé à la
médecine de prévention à savoir la
médecine
et le constat est accablant une médecine
une médecin pardon sortie de sa retraite
effectue des vacations dans le seul
arrondissement d'oriaac voilà comment
est doté à l'heure actuelle le
département en matière de médecine
scolaire ce n'est malheureusement pas
propre Cantal selon un rapport du député
Renaissance robareda 8 enfants sur 10
n'ont jamais vu de médecins scolaire et
seulement 20 % des élèves ont bénéficié
de la visite obligatoire des 6 ans le
déficit serait estimé entre 300 et 400
médecins par rapport au nombre de PO
financer pourtant son rôle il est
capital il réalise des bilans de santé
peut détecter des pathologies des
troubles de de l'apprentissage pardon
des situations de maltraitance met en
place des projets d'accueil
individualisés qu'on appelle les paiai
monsieur le sénateur comment expliquer
l'état de délabrement de la médecine
scolaire et quelles sont d'après vous
les solutions pour y
remédier alors c'est un c'est un sujet
tout à fait essentiel je rappelle que
les visites scolaires sont obligatoires
donc on est sur des enjeux de santé
publique de
prévention prévention en tout genre y
compris du harcèlement scolaire dont on
parle beaucoup et aujourd'hui la
situation est tout à fait catastrophique
alors pas seulement dans le Cantal mais
d'une façon générale en France et depuis
des décennies on a laissé se dégrader
les choses du point de vue de la la
médecine scolaire alors que c'est une
obligation première de l'État ceci dit
la question de la médecine scolaire
rejoint le problème plus général de
l'offre de soins et notamment dans les
territoires ruraux aujourd'hui il y a
des postes qui sont non pourvus donc il
va falloir trouver euh des des solutions
il y a deux en tous les cas là aussi
comme comme je l'indiquéis tout à
l'heure sur autre sujet on on est au
bord de la rupture on manque de médecins
dans nos territoires ruraux pas
seulement d'ailleurs mais dans les
territoires ruraux en particulier on
trouve plus de médecins pour la médecine
scolaire moi je défends l'idée d'une
façon générale alors il y a eu la
question du numérus closusus je n'y
reviens pas qui a été assoupli mais les
effets sont à 10 ans donc sur cette
questionl je défends l'idée de la
nécessité au moins pour un temps donné
dans l'attente que le numérus closus
fasse son effet de la régulation des
médecins je parle des médecins libéraux
et si on manque de médecins scolair
c'est parce qu'on manque de médecins
dans les territoires ruraux d'une façon
générale mais c'est aussi parce que la
rémunération n'est pas au niveau un
médecin scolaire aujourd'hui qui est
salarié donc a une rémunération au moins
au moins moitié moindre qu'un médecin
installé en en libéral donc il y a le
problème du manque de médecin il y a la
nécessité de réguler je défends cette
idée et je pense qu'on finira par y
arriver et puis il y a la nécessité de
mieux rémunérer les médecins scolaires
si on veut que ces postes soient
attractifs aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
médecins qui préfèrent le salariat que
s'installer en libéral mais en médecine
scolaire non parce que la rémunération
est insuffisante on a des médecins des
médecins scolaires qui ont des
rémunérations je le redis moins de la
moitié de de ce que gagne un médecin
salarié en dehors de la médecine
scolaire donc il y a des vrais sujets
c'est une priorité c'est une obligation
de l'État
d'offrir aux enfants des visites
médicales donc c'est une obligation de
l'État je pense que la première des
choses à faire c'est mieux rémunérer les
médecins pour rendre ses postes
attractifs dans le Cantal vous le
souignnez tout à l'heure on a trois
arrondissements il y a un arrondissement
où il y a plus de médecins scolaire
Saint-Flour un deuxième arrondissement
moriaac où il y a plus de médecin
scolaire et le trisème arrondissement
tenez-vous bien c'est un médecin
retraité qui fait des vacations pour
pour les enfants ça n'est plus ça n'est
plus possible donc oui il faut il faut
il y a un sujet il y a une priorité une
priorité très urgente merci merci
beaucoup pierre pour votre intervention
on va regarder la Une du journal La
Montagne qui est consacré à ce sujet de
la mine scolaire avec ce titre la santé
scolaire tous Bernard delcro on va
revenir sur la question des
collectivités territorial car vous
travaillez beaucoup sur ce sujet au
Sénat la semaine dernière c'était le
Congrès des Maires de France et la
première ministre isisabeth borne a
annoncé une hausse de 100 millions
d'euros supplémentaire de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement qui est versée
chaque année par l'État aux communes au
final cette dotation et bien elle va
augmenter au même rythme que l'inflation
vous saluez cet effort de l'État alors
oui je porte un amendement qui sera
examiné au cours de cette semaine qui
demande une augmentation de la DGF de
100 millions d'euros la première
ministre a annoncé cette augmentation
donc évidemment je suis satisfait notre
groupe d'ailleurs porte cette cette
demande d'augmentation de 100 millions
et ce que nous défendons là aussi pour
des questions de justice et d'équité
territoriale cette fois-ci nous
défendons l'idée que l'augmentation de
la DGF aujourd'hui dans le PLF prévu à
220 millions qui passera donc à 320
millions avec les 100 millions d'euros
supplémentaires que nous demandons et
qu'à accordé la première ministre nous
demandons à ce que ces 320 millions
d'euros supplémentaires soient ciblés
sur les collectivités les plus fragiles
celles qui en ont le plus besoin parce
que là aussi il faut de la justice et de
l'équité et derrière les moyennes
affichées sur la situation financière
des collectivités se cache des disparité
très grande donc ces 320 millions
doivent aller sur les collecités qui en
ont le plus besoin d'ailleurs Emmanuel
Macron a annoncé au maire qu'il avait
reu reçu la semaine dernière à l'Élysée
qu'il souhaitait refondre restructurer
cette dotation de l'État au commune
selon vous comment faut-il s'y prendre
plus plus ciblé vers les communes
fragiles alors il faut il alors il
existe aujourd'hui des dispositifs de de
péréquation mais si vous voulez la DGF a
été on a empilé un certain nombre de de
de mesures de dispositifs de décisions
on a même figé un certaine une certaine
part de de la DGF qui fait que
aujourd'hui la DGF telle qu'elle est la
dotation GL global de fonctionnement tel
qu'elle existe pour les communes ne
correspond plus à aux besoins et à la
réalité des communes d'aujourd'hui donc
moi je suis pour évidemment cette
réforme mais il faut prendre le temps
d'y travailler parce que ça n'est pas si
simple tout le monde veut réformer la
DGF mais tout le monde pense que c'est
le voisin qui aura un peu moins et et et
et et nous un peu plus donc il faut ça
sera enveloppe constante ce qui veut
dire que si certains ont d'avantage
d'autres auront moins donc ça peut pas
se faire à la légère et je veux dire
aussi que à côté de la DGF il y a des
avancées importantes dans loit de
finance et je tiens à à les saluer
notamment sur un sujet qui me tient à
cœur qui est la dotation aminité rurale
c'est-à-dire la rémunération des
services rendus par l'espace rural à la
société toute entière la dotation
aminité rurale qu'on a réussi à créer il
y a maintenant 3 ans qui n'existait pas
et plus que doublé cette année elle est
à 40 millions d'euros en 2023 elle passe
à 100 millions d'euros en 2024 c'est une
vraie reconnaissance de l'apport de la
ruralité à la société Emmanuel Macron
souhaite et bien un nouvel acte de
décentralis ation c'est-à-dire que
l'État central donne plus de liberté
d'action aux collectivités locales
est-ce que vous y croyez vraiment à
cette promesse du président de la
République alors que beaucoup d'élus
depuis des années critiquent justement
sa politique qui recentralise le pouvoir
à Paris alors il faut trouver le bon
équilibre mais je pense qu'il faut aller
plus loin dans la décentralisation et
laisser plus de liberté mais aussi plus
de responsabilité du coup au aux élés
leau en même temps il faut faire
attention l'État doit rester pilote dans
un certain nombre de de domaines qui
sont stratégie qui relève vraiment du
régalien et vraiment de sa
responsabilité on a parlé tout à l'heure
de la médecine scolaire c'est un vrai
sujet qui relève de de de la
responsabilité de l'État donc oui à plus
de décentralisation vu surtout un
assouplissement des règles et des normes
à plus de liberté pour les élus locaux
en même temps on reste bien dans un un
pilotage national sur des sujets qui
sont stratégiques merci beaucoup Bernard
delcro d'avoir été notre sénateur du
jour merci à vous